okay welcome to this video Wolverine yep
that's a frequent opponent three out of
seven that's not that's not very good
his rating is pretty low at the mood i
think he was much higher me check that
five-minute yeah he was on two thousand
four hundred and some point yeah not a
surprise I think he places t three
setups if i'm not wrong yeah here we go
and he's just one of those guys who just
place move move move move and doesn't
care much if it's good or not he just
plays quickly so I've tried to be a bit
quicker about it as well so Nyjah for
may be coming so let's protect f7 a bit
okay I can go see five I don't know if I
should let's do that and no well mr. pc
okay i see six is not terribly bad i
mean it loses a tempo probably but yeah
it's not it's not really really a big
issue yeah it's not a big issue but it's
an issue can't put it back him no then
he takes 26 stop and not so quick i came
but put this here yeah it irritated me
that at c-6 move but ok i really don't
think it's a huge problem still a go he
can go F for but it's just good maybe
yeah it's not not a bad idea maybe and i
know he goes deform that's really a
difference now that wouldn't have been
possible with them with c5
okay better better late than never
jay is the all those pieces on the
kingside like Queen only three 903 i'm
not sure that they do much what level
ghost-like see for Luke 28 gaining space
yeah I'm okay I think it's probably
about equal just I just play quickly I
quicker than usual because he also he is
a quick player and I don't want any yeah
any nonsensical time thing at the end so
what about this night over to e6 maybe
couldn't go rook the eight I ok could
have gone up yet but like to trade rooks
night is not bad on e6 can go to g5 or
possibly to f4 in the right moment
most important thing is stay I had on
the clock I really have this somehow I'm
remember remembering time time
situations here against him so on I try
to be a bit quicker here than usual
check yeah the end game is definitely
fine for me I have more space yep that's
good I'm just a bit better here just a
little bit check yep hmm a little bit
more space it's nothing that white
should lose it's still very dry but I I
like my my chances here it can get the
night over to be four but from that
doesn't have much much ideas many ideas
much ideas very bad english I think many
ideas so f6 up just trying to fix his
pawns on or keep his pawns on light
squares and my king my king is a problem
hmm double attacking H 495 silly that I
played badly I cannot protect both pawns
him
wow I really screwed that up from a
better end game 2 of us and game okay ah
yeah it wasn't like I wasn't seriously
better but black definitely had a slight
advantage them so there can I fight you
a little bit at least that's difficult
but I can I can try maybe over here
tries to a check the pawn or what
exactly c4 I can go to c5 his Knight has
to protect g2 at the moment ok can you
can get try to get the king over to g3
but ok I can i can move over here maybe
g-form I'm getting rid of this pawn I
will know like he takes down here hmm
huh what a bad game camp on Kim
yeah I don't know I often have problems
with them players who just play
basically just shuffle around do nothing
and then I tried to do something and I'm
kind of playing playing stupid stuff it
happens quite often I'm often too
ambitious if I feel they they play like
second-rate moves or something I try to
be ambitious and then I'm killing myself
this is really happening too often but
the endgame was fine I just um it's a
very pretty bad night okay well how how
stupid did I play that one night is just
terribly placed there I can maybe take
on e5 I know this one Jeff okay yeah
okay let's black resins very idiotic
loss yeah so in this end game black is
slightly better because of my better
structure he has pawns on light squares
and I have a space advantage but I
really played I didn't play that right
h4 h4 it's not it's strategically right
but it's at the wrong moment I have to
have to play king king g7 first and get
the King it to the middle yeah yeah okay
it's it's it's based it's almost
impossible to win this kind of position
but black is a little bit more
comfortable here he has no real idea you
can just shuffle around do nothing but
here this is a bit of a problem I mean I
can still take and be okay but after f6
this is stupid how long did I take for
that like four seconds I that's stupid i
should have thought about this a bit I
ok those kind of retreating news RI easy
to overlook but it's it was some yeah
should have should have seen it
okay I was very happy to go into the end
game because as I said like it's just
slightly better here check but um sure
this is right I guess oops sorry 95 I
guess is right check yeah yeah I have to
go King g7 first and then i can i can
try around a little bit in this end game
but it's probably going to be a draw if
he goes like H for him putting something
on a dark square g3 f4 yeah that's
that's very dry I have to slide about a
bishop in more space but it's a draw
yeah and the way it went I just belong
at the porn and with it the game after
that year you're just good you just lost
chairman it was basically I think
correctly correctly played this in this
game okay yeah I can try to keep more
pieces on here this is certainly
possible I mean queen d7 was a bit of a
was like play it simple I had more time
and I was just have a slightly better
position hey I could have kept the
Queen's on but ultimately it's just I
just blundered there there's this palm
and hand it to the point for free
basically okay thanks for watching